こんにちははじめ社長です
皆さんに皆さんに隠していたことがあります実は私実は私基世町の先祖は
[音楽]
ん
有名人だったかもしれん
それぞれの真実のところはわからないんですけどたぶんねハ分月で僕のセンズは何か僕
の記憶が正しければなんですけど昔家の人と話した時僕聞いたことあるんですよ
なんだね復刊触れよを極寒でちょっと今日は実家に電話して僕の先祖が本当にすごい人
だったのかどうかちょっと確かめてみよう
と思いますやっぱりねぼくそうだと思うんですよなんか
あるんですよ神に近い何かを持っているとあの自分でも思ってるんだやっぱなんかせん
ぞ的に何が特殊な能力を授かっててそれを僕受け継いでおり気がするんですよ
それはちょっと実践今日ね家に連絡して聞いてみようと思いますちなみにあの僕の記憶
が正しければ
僕の家計の先祖は
kk 閉経らしいです
源氏平氏っているのですからの兵士の方です
開けてますね現在には負けているもののまぁ逆に言うと現実源氏と闘いへ待ってる歴史
全然わかんないんだよなぁ原前にやっぱフォロバされてるなぁ
キッツ俺保護されてるのかなとメンバー平清盛とかいますねハイランドマッサカード
[音楽]
全然わかんないやその昔にやっぱそのペーシュと源氏がその超争ってた時期の兵士んな
んで
まあ現地には負けましたけど結構日本国内だと最強レベルのチームだったってことで
まつげたいです山田これが本当のとかわかんないんですけど僕の本当に記憶助ければね
ふん兵士の
生き残れなんですよ違ったらまず恥ずかしいんですけど一回
を打ち上げをしてみますかもよ
アンも女性
あっ始めです
アバン3人塩
なかなかかまじゃねーよ
おばあちゃんいいよあのちょっと聞きたいことが1個ありましてね
うーんなんか昔じゃばちゃんと離す取ってさー
なんか昔ばあちゃんと話すとってなんかうちの家計の先祖が兵士だったみたいな話せ
んかったっけ
[音楽]
姉ああの家のさんほらなんかばあちゃんの話とって家の
風先祖さん兵士やっぱと話してん買ったっけ
あんっばあちゃんの実家ねんんんッ
[音楽]
ん
ゲイ取らないけど思ったんだけどさよねーっ
[音楽]
いや
五箇山って場所があるのね
打つ分車要するにアレでしょ源氏に負けた後ってことやろーっ
えっうわぁ
によってからかな
中谷ない見込んで売買されていた
あなるほどでもあのハイばあちゃんってけどう愛は少しなからもう平気後を継いでると
いうことやねぇ
んだろう
はいはがないなるほど園
そっか落ち武者カーを2
あんまりカッコいけないねえええ
要約すると
ばあちゃんちの家計が平家ねー
生き残りだったって言え完全ね
ミイラぷりっ軽いといううーんなるほどねああああちょっと嬉しくなっちゃった
ありがとうございます
you
0言ってキープんだ望むわかりました
貴重なぞありがとうございます今け
いいにゃんだからああああそうよねわけじゃないけど
the 僕がちょっと登っておりませんいやー
敵だけ付いたら空いたも播種08クレカも入れない方ゴメン投げたねーよとか
はいはーいんじゃねえよねはーい
配備
はいというわけでみなさんに聞きますでしょうかフェイス吐息のコインらしいんだけど
を潰したらしいですまあそりゃそうですよね順次に負けてますから源氏に負けたものの
日本のね大勢力の一部である平家の1残りがなんとかばあちゃんの住んでた地域に
逃げ込んでそこでなんとか子せそを残した中にうちのばーちゃんが言ってあの婆ちゃん
とじいちゃん
何結婚して父ちゃんが生まれて母ちゃんと結婚して by がいるっていう
直接的な血はつながってないんですけども閉経も家を継いでいる
ということなんだろうねぇ
[音楽]
me
えっ x 件ずに勝ちたかったなぁ
いいというあのちょっとちょっとあのたぶんみんなまったくこんなこと知らなかったと
思うんですけどうっすらなんか記憶にあってなんかちょっと真相を確かめてみようかな
と思ってあの婆ちゃんに電話してみました
あの特にオツウはないですよし